foreign
and the ability to change the world as
essential to The Human Condition and you
have it as a personal experience
if if you could have not changed the
situation you were in
um
would that have changed the fundamental
of the human condition for you and how
do you see that in more general terms is
it an essential element of the human
condition that we think we can change
our condition
um I guess so when I hear your question
I think that actually I wasn't able to
change my condition
um so a lot of people come up to me and
they hear about the work I did where I
carried a mattress everywhere I went as
long as I went to school with the
classmate who assaulted me and they're
like
um well did it work did did Colombia
then kick him out did he then get put in
jail but the reason I made it was that
Colombia had already decided to not do
anything about it and the police had
already decided to not help right I I
was in a situation where I was like okay
I'm completely powerless but from that
place of powerlessness where can I find
creativity right how can you work with
powerlessness and actually end up not
necessarily gaining power I don't have
any like
grandiose visions of myself is this
all-powerful being but
um
where's the room for play and creativity
and can can I produce something from
here
um and I do think that
ultimately if if productivity and the
ability to create is a form of change
um it is a form of agency right the
ability to have control over our
situation so
so I think sitting with the
powerlessness was actually and the and
the fact that I couldn't change my
situation was
um
was actually where I was able to create
something new
yeah so you found the new path in your
Human Condition yeah I want to move this
on to you Andrea um through your work
with becomes a very disempowered uh
groups of people
um how do you see this question that
should we no follow commute and see
um freedom and the ability to change the
world as essential for I guess human
existence or if people can't change it
then what happens to the human exists in
their sense of it so I think that the
response to that question is often a
very self-serving and lazy response the
problems are overwhelming they're too
big so therefore we throw up our hands
and I think that that's rooted in how we
Define change it comes down to what is
change how do we
interpret that word if change means the
eradication of poverty
or the eradication of sexual assaults on
campus then we're always going to be
Sisyphus in a sense right but there are
all kinds of ways in which change
presents itself and manifests right in
the lives of people one way that I would
like to highlight is another person I
wrote about named Faith Hester
African-American teacher in a school
where there were shootings all the time
she was also the teacher of one of the
children of the man I mentioned before
Supreme
she had gotten out of the projects
gotten two master's degrees and then
returned to her community to try to lead
the way forward for other children who
reminded her of her former childhood and
she kept seeing that they didn't expect
to live beyond 21 because so many had
been shot in the school and the violence
is at an all-time high now in New York
City but this was gun violence was gang
related stuff and so she came up with an
idea
her idea was I'm gonna have you all
right your obituary
it was a very controversial thing to do
to go into class the parents freaked out
they said what are you doing this is not
homework these are sixth grade boys and
girls you need to write your obituary
but here's the only condition is that
you don't get to die until you're 70.
how do you imagine your life was lived
and I asked her why did you do this and
she said because I wanted them to see
that they are the authors of their lives
just to imagine yourself
for going forward in time to 70 which
was unimaginable to them got them
thinking in new ways now one of those
children actually was shot dead several
years later did it really change in some
ways it's it's a hard thing to measure
but I would argue that because change is
such a hard thing to measure we must
believe in it yeah
interesting and Paul I'm only bring you
in here how do you see because evidently
that change at Princeton was very
important for all the people who come
into Princeton but for all the others
how do you see change as essential to
The Human Condition for them
well I do think we have to believe I use
I've used this phrase
um a couple of times we I I certainly
have to believe that change is possible
I have to believe it not and I I have to
believe it on behalf of my children
apart from anything else I have to
believe that the world that they are
growing up in
um
and what assails them on every front
Prime frankly primarily
the state of the planet
that's the Big E so far as I'm concerned
and I think that if we give up on okay
we may know that eventually the Sun is
going to burn us up but that's a bit on
the road
and we want to make sure that while the
sun is in Waiting that we actually do
the very best we can and and we have to
find ways of of me of making sure that
global warming is brought down to a
minimum and I have and I have to I see a
shaking of the head I have to believe
that we're going to be able to do that
because if not it's it's just too
horrendous to uh to to to imagine right
and then we can all lie down and die
tomorrow we want to move on to this to
the second scene but it's a good lead
straight into it because was Kafka right
in recognizing that we are limited by
culture upbringing organization leaving
us little room to act so it's like the
opposite side of this question so I'll
go straight on with you Paul and say but
that's finding countries that are more
powerful what if you're a peasant or
fisherman on Samoa Islands and you see
the water rises a certain number of
centimeters each year and everyone moves
into that little patch that is left how
much power do you have to change
anything and how do you live if you
can't see the power I mean you become
Kafka SK and say run around a castle
where you can never get to the authority
that could change what you wish to
change well I agree that if one is
standing on on that island and watching
the waters Rising
and they're doing their best to try to
to to to make some difference and it may
not happen it may not work out but what
I'm
calling for is at least that we make an
effort uh to to put things right
um and uh you know we may know that at
the end of the day it's going to be very
difficult we may even know it's it might
be impossible but we cannot stop trying
yeah and I think that is a cure for Emma
because trying is exactly what you do or
whether you're caring I mean you have to
imagine am I carrying a heavy mattress
around the campus of Colombia every day
not one day or a week every day for a
year I mean that's quite a commitment to
changing something that eventually you
feel you couldn't change but somewhere
you change something else in that
process but I think Paul just want to I
was just going to say for example I
vividly remember Emma's
um
protest and I would like to and I will
never forget it
any more than I will forget the tortoise
and I believe
that the fact that you did that
well I I would like very much to believe
that somebody who might have thought of
doing something inappropriate who might
have thought of
engaging in an inappropriate advances or
sexual activity might actually have
thought you know what
maybe I shouldn't do that
you know so it's the the side effect
coming totally but I want Emma to not
yeah talk about how you see it for
having done that in a way
if you were in a situation you couldn't
go against directly The Authority you
found your way
how you compare that to kafka's line of
thought that you can't change it you're
in this situation there are bigger
authorities than you and
you do you chose to do something anyway
without always be your choice do you
think everyone should choose that is
there other ways you see what is
necessary
so first of all I think 100 we can all
agree that we need to believe in change
right without that I mean on an
emotional level God what a bleak world
we would live in and and half of like I
think philosophy is about defining how
we want to move through World in a way
that's going to make life manageable for
us and inspiring for us so I think of
course let's agree change is possible
and then I love the story you brought up
about
um this this uh
this assignment that the teacher gave to
kind of inspire
these children to understand how you can
have agency in your life
um because I think really the question
that we're trying to get at is not
whether or not change exists it's about
how do we make that happen right and I
think ultimately for me I had to reframe
that question for myself as not one of
okay
there are all these problems in the
world and how can I change them
it was more about saying how can I
change what I'm doing
right
um because at the end of the day I don't
have power over the New York police
department or power over Colombia like I
only have power that really extends at
you know to the limits of my skin and
the reach of my words right so how can I
change what I'm doing
um to make the best out of this
uh for all intents and purposes
remarkably powerless situation I find
myself in and once you
take control over this body and these
words that we
we are we've been gifted with I think
that's where we can
that's where change starts right yes and
I'd love to to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas